What did the ocean say to the beach? Nothing, it just waved. Nice, okay. It's pretty good. You want one last one? Yeah, please. Where do you learn to make a banana split? I don't know where.
Sunday school. Oh, man, that's good. Welcome to Smartless banana split. I don't know where. Sunday school. Oh, man, that's good. Welcome to Smartless, everybody. Welcome, everyone. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. I've been watching all these interviews with William Freakin, who direct the movies that we can't name, but amazing interviews. Are we celebrating a life lost? Yeah, we are. He was a tremendous artist and just one of the funny things I just read this thing, so I'm talking about going to this,
speaking to these students and the students, and I'm about to shoot my student film, what format should I shoot it at? And he said, who gives a shit? Is that true? William said that. I'm sure you're stirring. Oh, maybe, maybe,
I'm, he directed a scary movie that I can't watch today because it's so scary. Hey, Sean, I know we talk about this a lot, but it's enough from me, from my mouth. What? No. You being in New York. I know. I know. So dumb. Can we have a date? Now, I'm sure this is going to air past the day because I feel like we're close.
How much longer? Three weeks, 21, Sean. Sean, I got sent a picture yesterday from somebody whom you do not know, my friend Elizabeth, and she sent me a photo of her partner, a center photo of her. She didn't want to leave her seat, and he took a photo,
because she was out your show in the balcony, and she was so moved. She was sat there for like 20 minutes, like just reacting to it. She was so moved by you for so nice. It's so nice. Yeah, wow. It was two nights ago. I mean, that's so nice. That's your story. Yeah, wow. It was too nice to go.
I mean, that's so sweet. It's, it's, please tell her, thank you. And, um, wait, two things though. One is Scotty being stuck here, J. T. Your Point, treated me to a helicopter ride the other day. Will. Yeah. Hopefully he wasn't flying. No, he was not flying. Okay. And we flew so close to, because we haven't left.
They're done anything in six months. Um six months, lyric apartment theater, apartment theater. And, uh, and so we flew around and the Kyla copper came really close to the Statue of Liberty. Like, really close. It was unbelievable. I never seen it that close. So Scotty just said, hey, let's go take a helicopter trip around the city. Yeah, because we haven't done anything just to do something. Just to tell you. Sounds great. Have you ever done that? No, I would love to.
Now, I'm a little, I'm not a huge fan of helicopters. I love their mobility, their flexibility, and all that stuff. But, you know, there's zero glide potential. I get it's the glide. It's the glide. What do you mean glide? Well, I mean, it's sort of a, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's fools comfort anyway to think, you know, the plane has glide potential if the, if the engines go to
shit. Well, the guy told me that, the guy's like, because I'm like, what's the plan? He's like, oh, no, if the end, you started the trip, we were in the air. And I talked about it. I shouldn't have, because it freaked me out. And he goes, look, if the engines fail, and they won't, he goes, you just glide down to the bottom. It's got like that potential. So is he like helicopter does it? Yeah, what kind of helicopter were we on? Did it have a bunch of, I don't know, is it was a wings on it? Or a bunch of birds attached to it? You're seeing a second kid who's dropped. Just falls, man. Yeah, I mean, there's, there's some physics and yeah, so anyway, I mean, listen Don't think that's how any of us none of our listeners none of us. That's not how we're going no
I know I know what you mean when the thing took off and you know wobbles when it takes off left to right left to right Yeah, and it's like it's pretty scary. You're gonna choke on a wanton one day And that's how you're gonna go Like I can get one morning here And that'll how you're gonna go. Like, Scotty, I can get one more in here. Give it a minute, man. And that'll be it for you. Just a word to one time. Oh, one time. Sorry, you kidding?
That sounds pretty. He's gonna choke on the fucking heel of a loaf of wonder. He's like, well, I'm still bread. I'll just have the heel. There's a little bit of that. Hold it on, son. You ever make bread balls, or you take the center of the white bread
and you just, we'll ball it up with a something. Look at it, it's a bread meat ball. I collect heels. I just make heels. All my sandwiches are from heels of loads of bread. We ate, we ate tortillas, just a tortilla. You know shit, what's 9am? So that makes sense.
Hey, listen. We never make bread balls. You. Whatever, my bright ball. Hey, you know, you know, I love me some music. I love music. And, and I love all kinds of different music. Man, I always have. I've always had a, I like to think that I have an eclectic taste because sometimes I think, well, I'm just kind of a dinosaur,
sort of 90s indie rock guy, but I'm not. I'm kind of all over the place. You're the one tall Paul Simon to go down to Africa and do Graceland, right? You're on the inspiration for him. You've explored these sounds? But I've been into, you know, we've had a lot of great musicians on the show,
and I've been a friend of them all, whether it's from sort of new wave or, you know, whatever, to classic rock and roll, to, you know, whatever, to classic rock and roll, to, you know, I don't know, just everything. Think about it. And today's guest is such a representative of an entire genre of music that they kind of inspired so many musicians, and not just of their genre, but of all genres. It's so rare when somebody
from one genre is able to inspire people across all different types of music. You got Madonna. This person, this person is, he's, he's, he's, he joined us from overseas, born in Denmark, and then moved to the U.S. and formed a band that has sold nearly 120 million albums worldwide. That's my... Generating more than 15 billion streams. He's from Denmark? Yeah, I mean, nine Grammy Awards, two American Music Awards, multiple MTV Movie Video Awards, 2009 induction into the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
Just all over the place, they've done it. All they played with everybody. This is none other than one of my all-time faves. It's Lars Ulrich of Metallica. Good Lord. Ways. And now the high-tech reveal, see if I can do this. Oh my God.
Oh my God. No way. No way. Also known as a high. My name is Brett Balls. I like Brett Balls. No way there. Also known as, hi, my name is breadballs. I like breadballs. That's breadballs. Breadballs, I like breadballs.
Oh my God. Or otherwise known as Michael Cooper's best friend. How's Cooper? Yes, that's right. Michael Cooper, he's the texting me as we're speaking and he's texting you. You know, now Michael Cooper's got one of these ailments that I think affects a lot of people
on the next thing. Tell us who Michael Cooper is. He's a friend of yours. He's a guy I used to work with. Sure. And now he's working with fans here, folks, than me. But he uses the send button as a period when he texts people. That's a, yes.
That's a 23 text showing up at one time. This is a normal five minutes of Michael Cooper, but they're all sent with love and kisses. I love them. And there are pictures of himself driving. How many pictures of Michael Cooper? Do you have of him driving? Driving, showing off a watch or a new hairstyle
or a new set of glasses. You know, I'm not on, I didn't sign up for the Cooper fan letter. I love him now. As long as you have an iPhone and a text message thread with him, you're in that fan club. I love him. Look at what I just want to say, one thing that,
and I'm sure you guys have heard this before, but you don't need guests on your show, just the seven minute banter there before the reveal. That's, that's plenty. It's all done. I've taken, I've taken some potential Metallica titles away from this. I think bread balls is the one to be. I like zero glide potential. That sounds more like an album title. Great hard rock title. Yeah, I think sure that's, you know, that's like, well, they did it before. It's called Led Zeppelin. Yeah, right.
Zero glide. Yeah, there's a lot of bad jokes in there that we should shy away from. And then the last thing I would say also, is it Madonna? I like that one too. That's she's the mayor of all genres. Dude, dude, Lars, thank you for doing this, man. It's so great to have you. Right back at you. And I had the good fortune of hanging out just a couple times with Larris a few years
ago through mutual friends. That's right. And I've always, and of course, I didn't want to, you know, drill you with it at the time and, and Baris, you have always been such a fan of Metallica and your music. And, and one of the things that I did not know, and I guess a lot of hardcore Metallica fans did know this was I didn't know that you actually moved to the States just to play tennis. I knew that you were a tennis player and that you were a competitive tennis player, but I didn't know that that was the whole purpose of your move was to play tennis.
Is that true? The whole purpose was to, so my father, I grew up in Copenhagen, Denmark, as you guys circled. And you were born there? Born, yeah. Born and raised in Copenhagen. And my dad was a professional tennis player. And I come from a family of tennis players. So his brother was one of the other greats in the country.
And at one point, the Davis Cup, the Danish Davis Cup team was my dad, his brother, and the captain was their dad. So it's a long line of famous tennis grates in Denmark, and I, of course, wanted to follow in their footsteps. So when I finished school in 1979 in Denmark, I ended up in Braydenton, Florida. The first year of Nick Boleter's tennis academy. No way. And you moved because of tennis?
Is that what you mean? Yes. Absolutely. Nick Bolotair, tennis camp, which at the time, by the way, was revolutionary. It was like the real place where a lot of these famous young tennis dedicated tennis players went. It was like the first of its kind, in my rather. Yeah.
And it was also a transitional time in tennis where, you know, up till the mid 70s to the late 70s, the best tennis players all over the world were the ones that had the most talent. But as it shifted in the late 70s, the best tennis players ended up becoming the ones that worked the hardest at it and played six, eight hours a day and doing drills and worked in the weight room
and all this type of stuff. That there was a seismic shift in the whole setup. And I went the first year to Nick Boleteris. And then after that, we moved out to Southern California, ended up in Newport Beach, where I was going to attend Carl Del Mar High School, with my dad's friend, the tennis great from Australia, Roy Emerson, his son Anthony. And so in Denmark, up through those years, in my junior years, I was ranked in the top 10 consistently in the country.
And when I came out to Southern California and went to Colonel Dillmar High School as a junior in 11th grade, I did not, I did not. This is true, Stuart. I did not make the fucking tennis team. I was not, I did not, this is true story, I did not make the fucking tennis team. I was not, I was not one of the, I was not one of the seven best players at Crowell the Mar High School. Geez. So the whole tennis dream and following in, in the Ulrich footsteps that came crashing down, no pun intended to the zero glide potential there, but that came crashing down in one afternoon,
and then rock and roll was hovering, hovering in the trenches and took over. But wait, so Lars, you make this, and you sort of, you talk about it very openly in the fact that, yeah, I knew that you had this, this, come from this dynasty, this Danish, tennis, dynastic family. And then you move to, you go to Nick Bolleterri and then you come to Southern California. And like you see in one afternoon, like all of a sudden, what they put, you try out, they put out the list for the tennis team, you're not on it. And you're like, well, there goes everything. Like, that was that. Yeah. I mean, you know, I've heard myself obviously tell that story 9,000 times. So it, it, it gets shorter and shorter and becomes more of a sound bite.
But it is pretty much what happened. Music was always hovering. And music was my escape away from the discipline of tennis. And I'd been playing both guitar and drums in Denmark. And as you, I was 17 at the time, as you, you get a little older, and you start drinking a few beers, and looking at the girls differently, and blah, blah, blah, blah, and things change.
And, but I was, it pretty much came crashing down. That's why. Did you teach yourself to play guitar and drums, or were you doing it like through a, in school? In Denmark. In school. What language are they speaking, Denmark? They speak Danish.
And he's... He's trying to contact you for a second. Sorry, Lars. So sorry for one second. So sorry, dude. And you still speak it? Just a second. I'm not a third, Danzke.
I have stayed to take Danzke. I have 100% Danzke, or I... But your mic's going out. Ville, Danzke. You're going over. I'm still, I'm still proudly, you know, there's only five million of us and we keep it, we keep it loud and proud and I'm still a Danish citizen actually and still travel on my Danish passport.
Wow, that's so cool. Yeah. Now, so, so then, so that you learn these two instruments in, in school, it in school, it wasn't a music school, was it? Or was just a... No, no, it was just Danish public school. Pick an elective and band was one of them and you gravitated towards those two instruments. Was that that simple?
Ish, yeah, yeah. I mean, I was, my dad, my dad's passion away from tennis was also music, so I grew up in a very musically rich household. You know, there was a lot of, you know, all the jazz greats from Miles Davis to Cold Train, to Charlie Parker, to Dexter Gordon, all these, you know, and a lot of Hendrix and Doors and Rolling Stones playing out of my dad's music room all the time.
So there was a lot of music in the family and in the household. Was there a particular band or drummer or guitarist that got you to want to, you know, jump into those two instruments? Or was it just that? When I was, I started going to concerts in Denmark early. I was nine years old when I went to see Deep Purple. And over the next couple of years, like 74, 75, I saw bands like The Sweet and Slade and Status Quo and Kiz came to Denmark in 76 and then it started to grab it,
you know, going into Thin Lizzy and Rainbow and so on. But Deep Purple was my first real music experience and has always been the North Star for me. What about drummers? Who are the drummers that you were like? Yes. Ian Pace from Deep Purple, the guy with the round glasses, who was just insane driving Deep Purple. I gravitated towards also Phil Rudd from ACDC, who's obviously very different than Ian Pace. But he was a huge inspiration.
How did it go over with your family? That was, you say I was a big tennis family, I'm assuming that there wasn't a lot of hard rock happening in the car on the way back and forth to the court. It's like, how did they feel about that? Although it was a lot of... There was a lot of anything happening in the car because I bite to school,
starting in second grade. That big sort of career pivot for you and lifestyle pivot for you, were they cool with that? Yeah, my dad was very forgiving with all that. Like I said before, his passion was music. He actually wrote about jazz music
for some Danish publications. And at that time, excuse me, in the 50s and 60s, especially Copenhagen, but Stockholm to a degree in obviously Paris were just the European, havens for American jazz music. So many of the American jazz grades came to Europe, spent a lot of time on Scandinavia. People like Ben Webster lived in Copenhagen,
Dexter Gordon lived in Copenhagen, John Chi-Kai, but Copenhagen was very much a hotbed for jazz music at the time. Growing up to, like, kind of at Jason's point, where you, your parent, because I was like, I we live we grew up in a super small house And I was always playing piano practice piano and drove everybody crazy because it was so tiny How in the world like Jason will what if your kids just I don't dad want to play drums? I mean that going on in the house constantly
We got the electric we got the electric ones now with it with the head Yeah, yeah, that's you're right. That's true. No, we didn't have that back in the day, right, Lars? They didn't have those back in the day. No, we, I had a room down in the basement, where I had a little music room where I had my records and my record player. And I got a drum kit, a small piece together drum kit down. And I could bash away down in the basement and do my thing down there without pissing off too many of us.
So good. I can imagine that going through the house all the time. I mean, it's great that you did it. And everybody did it. Now Lars, us soft actors, we fantasize about life on the, you're pretty soft too. Well, you're hard rock, you know, traveling and touring and having all that fun. And what you look so good, so healthy, so not like you've been on the road in like arguably
the biggest rock and roll band ever for years and years and years, has the touring change now in the past decade or so such that you don't look like death warmed over. What's, how is it all working now? You guys get to bed early. It's now a shake. Another good title. It's not 30 beers. It's just 15.
Yeah, it's a protein shake, right? It's a mindfulness. Yeah, you know, in the short answer is yes. You know, we just played a couple shows out at MetLife Stadium on Friday and Sunday here in New York where I'm checking in from and worn away up to Montreal in a couple days. Right. Right now we're playing every Friday and Sunday for the rest of the summer. We play two shows in each city.
So the travel is less and it's a weekend thing. And it is, it's protein shakes, it's tofu, it's vegetables. If my 20 or 30 year old self was on this podcast with your guys, he would be sitting going, what the fuck are you talking about? But you know, 42 years in, obviously you have to, to make these changes and growing up in a, you know, around tennis and growing up around sports. It's not that difficult for me to be rigid and disciplined. I barely drink.
I haven't had a drink in three months. I'll have a half a class of champagne and that's it occasionally, but other than that. Still playing tennis? I still do play tennis. Yeah, I love playing tennis and I love sports and I love being engaged and I work out. They have me chained to a peloton. Most of the time when I'm not doing podcast or playing watch shows. And so I do work out a lot. But it is true about the protein shakes
and we have a fortune to have a, you know, our great chef Simon who travels with us and hands us all kinds of healthy and it's healthy drinks and it's good. Listen, we've lived it. Lots of crazy fun. I mean, also we started, James and I met when I was 17. He was 18. We started Metallica. We put our first record out when we were, when I was 19 and we were touring the world, 19 and 20.
So we started early. Just some amazing. And, you know, you got to, you got to, we got a lot of that fun stuff out of the way. And I can access a good part of those memories when I want to some of them live really far back there behind doors that that are hard to open and probably shouldn't be opened. Yeah. this year and the only way to play shows like we just did out at MetLife Stadium here is to be in the best shape you can be. So, you know, all kidding aside and clichés. Yes, it is obviously pretty different than it was 20, 30 years ago and thankfully so because the victory now is the perseverance and being able to still do it. And that's kind of what
motivates us. Yeah, I bet it doesn't. I bet you can't imagine. I bet you're speaking about your younger selves. I bet you're 17 year old self when you met James Headfield and you guys formed Metallica. Can you imagine that all these years later, you guys would still be fucking rocking out and going and playing stadiums around the world. Yeah, it's pretty crazy. We've just, we've been playing. So I looked into it the other day. So we've played out it used to be called giant stadium
Now you have to say met life so you don't because you get into a whole divisive conversation That naming a giant in the jets. You don't want to you don't want to do that around here But we've played I just looked it up. We've played giant stadium nine times and And we've had an obviously a relationship with a greater New York tri-state area, whatever you wanna call it, for four plus decades. The two shows we just played this weekend were the two biggest shows we've ever played
in New York City. So that, that's amazing. So that's not a, hey, look how great big Metallica is or whatever. That's about the music scene, that's about post-COVID people want to come out and live again. That's about hard rock still. But they're not coming out for everybody, you know. You deserve credit for the longevity and the relevance and the quality of the music
and your relationship with your fans and all of us up, your mental health, right? Because if you guys were a disaster, people would probably get turned off by if there was a bunch of infighting and all that garbage. So you've kept it all together. Thank you. I appreciate that.
But I, you know, I think a significant part of what drives us to this day is that we're kind of led by the mantra of our best days are still ahead of us and our favorite record is the one we haven't made yet and that we actually made sure and professional at some point of view is for real one day. And we will be right back. Smart list is sponsored by BetterHelp. So, listen, unless you're a robot or just visiting from another planet,
you've got thoughts. You've got thoughts that sometimes are not that friendly and are difficult to process. Now, BetterHelp is right there in the title, right? Right there in the name. You can get some help to better process these thoughts at better help. It works. Do you ever find yourself just as you're trying to fall asleep or brain suddenly won't stop
talking. You know, do your thoughts start racing right before bed or at other inopportune moments? It turns out one great way to make those racing thoughts go ways to talk them through. With better help, therapy gives you a place to do that, so you can get out of your negative thoughts cycles and find some mental and emotional peace. If you're thinking of starting therapy, why don't you give better help a try? It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists at any time for no additional charge.
So I highly recommend just finding someone that you can just download your stuff, which at worst just treat them as a file cabinet. We can at least just deposit this stuff so they don't keep you up at night. Get a break from your thoughts with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartLess today to get 10% off your first month.
That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash SmartLess. We get support from Audible, the home of storytelling. You'll discover thousands of podcasts from popular favorites to exclusive new series, guided wellness programs, theatrical performances, comedy, and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities. We're now into experts and exciting new voices in audio. The Audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere while traveling, working out, walking, doing chores. You decide.
One that I'm really enjoying, written by James Clear called Atomic Habits. It's just basically, you know, it's not just another self-help book, it's something that like, you can actually put these things into motion, like these ways in which to make good habits pleasantly habitual. Does that make sense?
And as James says himself, tiny changes remarkable results. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or tech smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try audible free for 30 days. This show is supported in part by Zip Recruiter. We're not great at a bunch of stuff over here at SmartLess, but we are the best at a few things. Number one, Sean Hay are the best at a few things. Number one, Sean Hayes, best pianist at parties.
Okay, this guy can really tickle the ivories. Will Arnette is the best at, gosh, really nothing except maybe being the best Canadian on the podcast. The bad news there is that he's the only Canadian. Okay, so he gets something, that's a trophy. I'm the best at being long-winded and not interesting. Our sponsor, Zip Recruiter, is also the best at something. Finding top talent for your hard to fill roles.
So if you need to hire, you can try Zip Recruiter right now for free at ziprecruoter.com slash smartless. Zippercrooter's powerful technology does the work for you. It scans thousands of resumes to find great matches for your job. Zippercrooter lets you invite the most qualified people to apply for your job to help you stand out amongst the competition. When it comes to hiring, go with the best. Zippercrooter 4 out of 5 employers who post on Zippercruder, yet a quality candidate
within the first day. What are you afraid of? Go to this exclusive web address right now to try Zippercruder for free. Zippercruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's zippercruder.com slash smartlsss. Zippercruder, the smartest way to hire. And now back to the show. You know, I want to kind of give into a little bit about you and James,
you got, because you guys met at such a young age, talking about like the, you know, and that you seem to still have by virtue of what you just said. You still have this like drive to like create something new and you're still excited about that creative process. What was it about that when you guys met at such a young age with coming from such different backgrounds?
What was the thing that clicked for you guys creatively? Yeah, because before you answer that, just to piggyback on that, I think it's fascinating. What will just said, that at such a young age, you found somebody else that wanted to take it as serious as you did. What are the odds of that? Yeah. You know? And every time people ask me that question, I always have to throw in that the energy of
the universe is a big part of it because, you know, like you're saying, the two of us finding each other, you know, what we had in common, there were so many things we didn't have in common, but what we had in common was that we were both sort of loners. We were both, we weren't like outcasts in that sense or like the awkward weirdos, but we were loners and we were misfits and we were disenfranchised in a way that we just lived in our own worlds and listened to all music. When I ended up at Coral del Mar High School in 1980. Trust me, there was nobody else wearing an iron maiden t-shirt.
And so it was a pretty, it was a pretty isolated existence. And so what James and I ended up doing was we were the brothers that neither of us, you know, never had. And we started writing songs together and and just creating the world for ourselves that we wanted to inhabit. And at that time there was never anything about, you know, goals or success or we're going to be, you know,
famous or this is going to translate into something, you know, with the mainstream success, that there was none of that, because at that time, the music that we were into and the things that were turning us off were so edgy and so isolated away from mainstream acceptance that was never, that was never even the cards. But, you know, what's interesting about that, Laras, is that you guys were making like,
you know, whatever you want to call it, hard rock, heavy metal. You guys were making like music that was really driving it and it was not necessarily mainstream. And then I think about, I think I probably went through your four records in with, by the time you guys made Metallica, which is a lot of people called the black album, by the time you guys made Metallica, you really broke through to the mainstream. You had a few hits that were kind of like leading up to it, but then the black album really broke through. And in a lot of ways I've thought before,
I was like, is it that everybody else's tastes change or that you guys kind of, you guys prepared everybody to listen to this music. Like you guys kind of got them into this hard rock in a way. I don't know. I think you have to put the record companies in there when you answer that question. And so the record companies at that time
were the gateway to everything. So the record companies, it's like the analogy of said many times is that you walk into a restaurant and you can have anything that you want in the restaurant as long as it's on the menu. The record companies were the purveyors of the menu and so the record companies were only signing things that they thought would appeal to a large group of people. But hovering over in the left field were all these people like ourselves that wanted something that would anxieties and issues just like ourselves. And so slowly over the 80s, as more and more kids understood that they were music out there for them,
like the type of stuff that we were doing, they started moving further and further, left. They started moving the mainstream further and further out to where bands like ourselves were hovering. And there was that seismic shift then towards the late 80s when all of a sudden, the mainstream realized that there were other options that they had been fed over the years. Right. And you guys were like you said, lyrically, Sean, that way, and I don't know, lards, if you heard me before you came on, I quoted your song one. And I said, you know, take my brothers, I pray for death. uh, uh, you know, take my brothers. I pray for death.
Oh God, please take it. I did. Yeah. And like that, I didn't write that one down as a potential, but no, I know. I have the other ones. Well, you already have that song. That song already exists as a hit. And it's like, it's still hard to beat bread balls.
But that song is like, I mean, you think about you guys that, I mean, that song specifically is about a guy who's basically in a calmer right, he's kind of paralyzed, or what's the deal with that? Like, nobody was writing songs about that and everything. We spent a lot of time, we spent a lot of time sort of wondering what, you know, different mental states. And so at one point we were talking about what would be like
if you couldn't speak, see or or hear and you had no arms or legs But you were just a living conscious. What would that feel like? What what would go on inside you if you were just a living conscious? And then we found out about Dalton Trumbull's story of Johnny Gartis gun and then We wrote a song around that and then realized that there was actually a movie with Jason Robards that came out, I think, what, late 60s, early 70s. And that became our first video. And that was a four albums in. And at that time, we had never made any videos for MTV. And we were sort of the anti-MTV band, but we finally felt that we had an idea
that was worthy of making a video. And you guys remember something called dial MTV back or day. So the first day that that video premiered and was eligible for dial MTV had premiered at number one and it stayed at number one for like the next couple of months. And that was a significant, I think, a wake-up call to a lot of the industry,
them realizing that there was something else out there than I don't wanna mention names, but that that was out there at that time that was generating a lot of the attention. Something more than Frankie goes to Hollywood with the lasers. Way to go, JB. I mean, well, the dancing all around it. Do you miss videos at all?
We still make videos. We made for a new album. Now it's actually the opposite for the last two records we put out. We've made videos for every song on them because if you now, you know, so many people here, albums on YouTube, so you want to have a video that you've made yourself for every song on your album rather than having somebody else make them. So we've made videos for every song in the last album that just came out a few days ago. I love that. I remember long, long time ago, I don't remember the year, but just when you're dead. This is when you're dead. When my dad left, yeah, it was 1975. No.
Do you have a question for my dad? I'm trying to drive and just light up the rear positraction and go. No, I have a question. You know, just like, just like Metallica, they turn professional one day. You guys should do this. We will try to do it.
No, I remember when hearing about you doing a concert in Antarctica, right? That's right. I was the only band who's played on all seven continents. It was sort of by chance. It was not something that we set out to do. Well, I don't think one would. But yeah. No, but it's not like you sit there and go, Hey, what should we do this year? Let's play all seven continents.
We were playing in Latin America. We were playing in Europe. We were playing in North America. We had shows in, you know, in Africa and Asia and all of a sudden it was like, whoa, there's a thing happening here. And we got an offer from, I believe it was Coca-Cola. It was soft drink in Brazil,
who said that they were putting together a competition. And the prize was to travel to an article and hang out and they wanted to know if we would come down and play for this group of soft drinkers. Was it cold? Well, it was December, which is their June, which is their high summer. And it wasn't as cold and it wasn't as frigid
and it wasn't as sort of otherworldly as you would expect it to be. Yeah, because I was gonna say, how do your hands work? But we were down there for a couple of four or five days. We stayed on an icebreaker and we stayed with all the contest winners and all our crew were all on this icebreaker together
which was super fun. And then we played on a Chilean research base and we played in a tent. And you guys know what Silent Disco is? No, we were already very busy. So every, exactly, everybody had headphones on. So the, I think there were like maybe 300 people there and total everybody had headphones on, so they could hear the music.
And so it didn't disturb the environment. It didn't disturb the penguins. It didn't disturb the other endangered species of animals that were there. And so we left no, there was not even, not even noise pollution. It's weird I last summer I was in New York and I saw these kids like late night and they're all in the steps of this church like midnight on a Friday night and everybody's moving
nobody's saying a word and I realize they've all got headphones on they're all jamming and they're all dancing to the song but you can't exactly the only thing you can hear in the room are the lead vocals and the drums. Other than that, all the amplified instruments are going through the headphones. So it was definitely a mind-fuck to be down there, a lot of fun and to answer your question.
It wasn't as crazy cold or as fucked up as you would imagine it to be. But it was cool. Well, I want to go back to James just for one second. Just talk about collaboration and sort of sharing power and creativity and not just with him, but with the rest of the band mates. I mean, you guys have been together and so successful and so harmonious, no pun intended for so long. Is there a secret sauce to that?
I'm sure there's some good leadership involved. Yeah, I would say the probably the word compromise. Sure. You gotta learn to compromise. You gotta learn to know and to lead and you gotta learn when to step back. James and I have been obviously in the band since the beginning and we, I guess, we steer most of the creative conversations and we take turns steering and I think compromise is the key thing. And if you want to be in a band in your 50s and 60s,
and really want to be in a band, you've got to learn to sort of work with the environment of sort of how to deal with everybody's personal needs. The reason that there is millions of bands how to deal with everybody's personal needs. The reason that there is millions of bands of people in their teens and 20s and fewer bands of people in their 50s and 60s is, you know, when people get older, they just don't wanna deal
with other people's shit. And you don't wanna compromise and you don't wanna, hey, I've got, you know, my son's graduation is the week of Lala Palusa. Oh, well, I guess we can't play Lala Palusa or whatever. So there's a lot of those types of conversations that take place. And we have a thing in our band where everybody gets a chance
to, you know, black dates out and put, you know, exes in a calendar and that can't be challenged. We're very supportive of each other's personal space. And we, you know, we put more resources and time into sort of the whole thing functioning as a band than we ever have before. And I'm not going to bullshit you. I mean, that doesn't get any easier as you get older now Most of the kids are grown up and and you know off to college or in their 20s So there's less concerns about getting home, but we you know we I mean 10 years ago we were tour in two-week increments
We would go on the road for two weeks go home for two weeks, you know go on the road for two weeks, go home for two weeks, you know, go on the road for two weeks, go home for two weeks. So we wouldn't miss, you know, being with our kids and all that stuff. It's gonna ask you about that about family. I mean, you guys must have had some very supportive and flexible families throughout all the way. Yeah, but we've also steered it in the direction of trying to keep all that, you know, as together as possible.
I'm sure it's the same with you guys, but you know, in our world, it takes a few years before you realize that you actually have a say in some of this. Yeah. When you start out, you just get handed a schedule there's like, and when you're 22 years old, hey, I just want to play as many gigs as possible
and travel as much as be as drunk as possible and get into all kinds of crazy shenanigans. But then you realize later, hang on a second, I can actually say, I only want to be on the road for three months, and then I want to spend three months at home. Or, you know, so, you know, as you go along and become more successful, you realize it, you have a saying this stuff.
Well, we're lucky because we started doing, certainly we started doing this thing in our 50s. And as we've done, and we've talked about maybe, you know, we went on, we did a short two or a couple years ago and we're talking about doing another one. But everything that we do, we always do with the understanding that like everybody's got stuff, and if somebody's got stuff, we never challenge it in that same way either because we know what life's like and it's kids and it's thing
and it's Sean's been doing his play for six months and like that's important. So we've got to honor that and that's a thing you got to do. I forgot to ask, because I've always wanted to know this. Favorite color? No, I was to ask, because I always wanted to know this. Favorite color? I think I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna, I was gonna,
I know that Sean was letting up. Favorite advertiser on the Chin Chin menu. No, no, no, no. What was, what's your favorite? Dipping sauce for the- Who came up with Metallica? No, Metallica, we're that kind of- Don't play Dipping Sauce.
The name? Yeah, man. Ron Quintana. Ron Quintana. Ron Quintana was a friend of mine at San Francisco. Up in San Francisco, there was a little bit of a different music scene than an LA when we started, and we started playing up in San Francisco early, and we had some friends up there
and so on, but one of the guys up there, Ron Quintana, he, back then, pre-internet, pre- you know, all this stuff, you know, if you wanted information about your favorite bands, you had to, you know, write to pen pals or, you know, and everybody, everybody that was really into music at the time made their own fan scenes, as they were called. So it was eight pages, stable together down at Kingco's about whatever their favorite French heavy metal band that five people had heard of was into. And so Ron Quintana wanted to start a little fan magazine. And he asked me one day whether he should call it Metal Mania
or whether he should call it Metallica. And I told him to call it Metal Mania. And we're taking Metallica. I'll hang onto the Metallica for you. And so I've been forgiven that. Thankfully a long time ago and Ron is still a good friend. It's cool. It's a fucking, it's a rad name.
It's good. Feels good on my tongue. So Lars, this is the stand shot. Oh, I'm sure you're done. Hey, Sean. Sorry to subject you to my dumb question here, but I asked, but I use my favorite answer. God, again, Lars, we're so sick.
I'm a city to play in. Isn't it cold playing without your top on? No. Sure. No, I don't know. Reef's not. Reef's not. Reef's not. Why is your hand always backwards?
What's going on? You don't want to see what lives under here trust me. Oh, what doesn't live under there? I want another craziest tourist story, like fan weirdness. There's something that went wrong on stage or during a set or like you got to have something that just was like, oh God, the worst one of all was blank. Well, we're very lucky.
I'll answer both. We're very lucky in that we have an incredible group of people that follow us pretty much wherever we go. We actually started selling tickets to them. On the last tour, we have something called a black ticket. So you can buy now a ticket that gets you into all the shows on a tour. And so there's, uh, there's, uh, hundreds, if not thousands of people, you know, we'll go out and play for, you know, six, eight weeks in Europe, order.
And it's, you know, we see all the same faces down front. No, so passionate and they come from all over from Latin America, from Asia, from Europe. So we have the black tickets. What's that black ticket running, Lars? Yeah. Yeah. The black ticket. Well, I know people, if you're interested, Jason, and you want to come out, it runs,
uh, it's got to be some kind of a break on it, right? 800, that's, what? That's a big break. Yeah. There's a big break. That's nothing. Uh, it's, uh's for all those shows. We tried to be his fan for. How much did he say?
How much did he say? $800. You can see all the shows in the entire tour. Fucking way. Now they don't get to jump on the plane. I don't get to jump on the plane. No, but I'm going to buy for I'm going to buy for all of us. Fuck, Lars. I'm going to get you one too. Yeah. You know what though? I wish'd had that, you know, I saw you guys. So, Lars, I saw you in Guns and Roses in September of 1992 at C.N.E. Canadian National Expression Stadium in Toronto. It was one of the fucking great concerts. All right. I'm in. It was unfuck in real. I was 22. Sure. And you guys rocked it out. And I have such a vivid memory of you. Got it. And even
what it was basically every song you guys played. And everybody in Unison rocking out, I've never seen it. I've never seen anything like it before or since, in the way the dedication and the sort of the rhythmic unison. It's very, very, very past religious stuff. Your eyeballs have seen from your position. You get to see the whole band in front of you
and then all of the people in the crowd. Dude, I'm telling you, it's bizarre. It was fucking images you have in your head must be. We're also now, I'll circle back to the question, the Chani was asking earlier and I'll give you a variation in what you just said about seeing all the people in front of me. So you talk about malfunctions. The first one that always comes to mind
because it left a deep, deep scar. You were talking about the black album will. And so we were touring on the black album, which was our most successful record, up till then. And we had been in America for maybe a year, year and a half. We'd done the guns and roses tour and we were starting in Europe a few months later and we were playing in London and at that time and obviously still you know London is just press and business and peers and you know publicity and all the
all the you know people from all from all the record companies and all the publicists and everybody from all of Europe are there. It's London and at that time it's all music magazines and weekly, like the enemy and Karrang and blah, blah, blah. And so we're playing in the round, which we still do. And I have a drum kit on either side of the stage, and halfway through the set, I'm supposed to run over,
and then the other drum kit, I'm supposed to sit on the other drum kit as it lifts out of the stage, and then I play the other half of the show over on the other side. We could probably guess what happened. So this is the first big show of this European tour. Everybody in our universe is there. And so the drum kit, you know, under the stage, I'm on the drum kit and it won't fucking lift up out of the stage. So my view is not 20,000 crazy
people in Wembley Arena, wherever it was. It's all the nuts and bolts and the steel and the 12 roadies that are down under the stage with like crowbars and fucking screwdrivers and hammers or whatever they're trying to do and they're trying to get this thing to lift up out of the stage. I ended up playing like a song in a half underground.
Under the stage submerged, just sitting there. And as Metallica was supposed to have all these articles written about the triumphant return back to Europe after three years after being the biggest rock band in America. The whole story was just about Larsus fucking drums that didn't want to lift out of the stage. Welcome back to Europe. Thank you very much. That's great. I love that. That is so great.
And so... So, what did you finish the rest on the other drum set? The rest of the show on the other. And eventually, with enough crowbars and determination, the drums ended up on stage where they belonged. That's good. We'll be right back. up on stage with their belong. That's good.
We'll be right back. Smilest is supported by state farm insurance can be confusing sometimes. That's why state farm is there for your what-ifs because they know the rest of your life is already full of thinking about other things like what if your life was a playlist. Imagine how crazy it would be. Your first song might be a noisy track called Kids, a second one, a spooky track called Home Ownership, then like a hundred more songs called Work, a second one, a spooky track called Home Ownership, then like a hundred more songs called Work, Health,
Pat, Cars, Yardwork, the playlist goes on. And once you put it on repeat and add shuffle mode, things might not sound all that jazzy. That's why the last track you'd wanna add to your life's playlist is called Insurance Uncertainties, with lyrics like, what if I'd like to add coverage to my policy? What if I have a question at 3 a.m.?
Well, there are some positive notes that can help keep your life in harmony. You can file a claim on the State Farm mobile app, talk to a real person, including your agent, and you can call day or night about insurance coverage and policy questions because that's just what they do. So no matter how noise
your life may get insurance can still be music to your ears like a good neighbor state farm is there call or go to state farm dot com for a quote today. Hey smart list listener. This episode is brought to you
and part by fan duel. Score early this with fan dual america's number because right now new cust dollars in bonus bets, g play say $5 bet. That's $150 in bonus bets win or lose. There's no better time to get
is so easy to use. There's a wide range of betting options, including spreads, player props, overunders, and more. Now, I'm trying to get them to book a bet for me on how long Sean Hayes will stay a part of SmartLess. They're saying the odds are so small that they just can't find anyone to balance out the other side of it. So I've moved on to Will Arnett,
still getting really long odds on him staying longer than maybe the next couple of weeks. But anyway, they will take most bets on things I think over there at FanDuel. So visit fandual.com slash smartlisten kickoff the NFL season fan duel, official partner of the NFL. 21 plus exclusions apply, C show notes for full disclaimer.
We get support from NetSuite by Oracle. Your business was humming, but now you're falling behind. Teams buried in manual work, taking forever to close the books, getting one source of truth is like pulling teeth. If this is you, you should know these three numbers. 36,025, one. 36,000, that's the number of businesses which have upgraded to NetSuite by Oracle.
NetSuite is the number one cloud financial system, streamlining, accounting, financial management, inventory, HR, and more. 25, NetSuite turns 25 this year. That's 25 years of helping businesses do more with less. Close their books in days, not weeks and drive down costs. One, because your business is one of a kind. So you get a customized solution for all your KPIs in one efficient system with one source of truth. Manage risk, get reliable forecasts, and improve margins.
Everything you need all in one place. I mean, since when has everything you need all in one place ever been a bad thing, right? That's the greatest thing. Right now, download NetSweets Popular KPI checklist designed to give you consistently excellent performance, absolutely free at netsweep.com slash smartless. That's netsweep.com slash smartless to get your own KPI checklist.
Netsweep.com slash smartless. And back to the show. Are you excited by anybody right now that you're comfortable saying that has sort of the same kind of early ambition that you guys had to sort of be a little left or a little right of what is being embraced, you know, that sort of real mainstream. You guys are really courageous by kind of pushing the envelope. Is there somebody in music right now that you're excited about their courage? I mean, there's a lot of great people in garages and in bedrooms all over, obviously,
making records on their computers now that don't need to go into studios and do the whole, the whole spiel that everybody had to do 20, 30 years ago. They don't have to rely on record companies. I think an artist like Billy Eilish, you know, what her and her brother did a couple years ago, those first records that were made at home on the computers is crazy cool and is so, it sort of epitomizes, you know, the shift of, you need a record contract and you need half a million bucks
to go into a proper studio and make a record now. And they made those first couple of records just at home on their computers. And that to me, it's indicative of the possibilities now that the technology, the four of us could make a record for the rest of the possibilities now that the technology, you know, the four of us could make a record for the rest of the afternoon and put it out tomorrow. Let's do it.
Jesus, where are we not doing this? Where are we not doing this? Why are we not doing this right? Fucking now, Lauren, do we want to break the internet or not? What are we doing? Well, speak a little bit more about that, about the record industry and stuff, not not to get sort of in the weeds about all that, but, you know, obviously there's been a
big, a big, big change in the record industry were streaming, etc. Yeah, and you're not really selling albums as much as more of kind of all a cart kind of songs that are downloaded on streamers, and then the bands really make their money curriculum if I'm wrong from touring now. And so I'm assuming that the bands, if they want to make money, they got to be on the road more. Are you guys on the road more? You guys don't need to make money. But how are you, how are you feeling about the way the, the business is sort of balanced right now as far as being out versus selling album, staying home and the, the, the, the ratio of that? Well, obviously it's changed quite a bit.
and the ratio of that. Well, obviously it's changed quite a bit. And in your guys' industry, some of the same things that we were dealing with 20 years ago are happening. I mean, big picture, and I know this may sound like a little bit of a cop out. I'm just happy that fucking anybody cares about what we're doing and she'll stop to see us play
and still stream or buy or steal our records or whatever. It, the engagement in self, I think, is the triumph and the victory. Obviously, it's way, way harder for a lot of the younger bands nowadays because they don't get the support of the record companies nowadays because they don't get the support of the record companies for basic things, just like gear and tour support. So there is very much of a different thing. It's, I just, you know, talent, good songwriting eventually will find a home with a larger group of people
and whether you do it from your bedroom or through a record company or whatever. I believe that everybody will be heard eventually if they're talented, but it is tough. It's tough for a lot of the younger bands out there and for a lot of the bands that, you know, 20 years ago could make a living playing clubs or theaters or have in a harder time now because they don't sell as many records and you really have to be out there and pushing it.
Do you feel like when you go and you make a record, like your new record, 72 seasons that you guys made, that came out this year and that you're touring, I think you're touring this year on, right? This is what the, on the new record. When you make that new record, when you guys have conversations about it coming out, like are you guys like, or I don't know, the record company or whoever,
it's such a different approach because you're not going to the record store, it's not sending out vinyl or it's not sending out CDs or it's not sending out. It's like load, load up the, the streamer or does that play it all into it? Yeah, I mean, it's the key thing, you know, as an artist, I think when you, you write songs and it's the same with you guys, you want to start a conversation. You want people to engage. You want people to hear your music.
How they hear it, I guess, eventually become second tier. And you understand that it's a changed model than it was 25 years ago, 50 years ago, or whatever. I think that in our know, in our band, we just love writing songs and we love making records. We love the creative process and that's, there are a lot of bands that have been around as long as we have that simply don't want to make records anymore because it either
doesn't work for them or the business model of it doesn't work for them and I can't speak for everybody else. We love writing songs. Being creative is a significant part of who we are and it gives us a chance to you know what what makes us stay functioning is that we go from writing to recording to playing gigs to writing to home. We're always changing up what we're doing. So we never get stuck in the sameness over and over. And so we're not always on the road. We're not always in the studio.
We're not always taking our kids to school or whatever we're not always doing the same thing. So you have to kind of keep just breaking it up and changing what you're doing. And so obviously, I understand that we're exceptionally fortunate, but our success gives us the opportunity to to sort of do all that. And but we would be if if somebody said you can't write or make records anymore, we would probably stop what we're doing because it's such an essential part of just our existence.
Sure, sure. And I love, by the way, I love that you didn't say exceptionally lucky you said it for you because you're not lucky. It wasn't luck that you guys got here. You guys are talented, but you do recognize the full story. You also have nowhere at minute 1590, as it said storyteller.
I know it's true, it's true, he's not so story-tellier. We, Lord, I have a list of words here not know it's true. It's true. He's not saying storyteller. We love the Lord. I have a list of words you're not to say on podcast. That's number seven. Yes. If we if we if we got a hold of if we got a hold of your personal music device, whatever it is that you that you use when you're like working out on when you're cycling or whatever doing whatever what's on there.
What do you listen? What gets you going? What do you like to listen to? Currently, I don't mean of all time, Mrs. Erly. It's very varied, obviously. I'll still circle those deep purple records from 50 years ago that I... Is there a genre you're not a fan of?
No, I mean, I listen to everything from rock music, to jazz music, to reggae, to pop, to hip hop, R&B. I think the easiest way to answer is, and forgive me again, if it sounds like a cop-op, but there really are only two kinds of music. There's great music and less great music, and so in hard rock, there's great music and less great music, just so in hard rock, there's there's great music and less great music, just like in pop or in reggae, you know, a couple days ago, driving back from rehearsals
out at MetLife Stadium. We were we're just going to think to a... We love Brunsky. I was pumping some bronsky beat and some... It's a one. Jimmy Somerville. Yeah, Jimmy Somerville. Beat boy, beat boy, hit that perfect beat boy. No way.
And you're listening to the happy Mondays. We're really listening to Stone Rose and Stone Rose. Tristan Memele, man. You know you speak so, man. Oh, Stone Rose of Fools. Who's gold? I love Stone Rose. Dinner, dinner Rose of Fools, go. I love Stone Rose. Dinner, dinner, dinner, dinner, and listen to that. So it's a lot of varied stuff.
A lot of varied stuff. To a lot of time. Lars, we're in the same, we're in the same. What about listening to a full album? And like since, since, people don't, yeah, people don't really buy albums as much as they used to. They're sort of pulling down kind of a single song here, Alacart there, whereas like Pink Floyd,
the wall comes to mind where there's a whole through line, a thread, a continuity, a thematic that goes throughout the whole album because bands knew that people would potentially buy an entire album. Is that a single? You're saying it to a history? And you're saying that they're telling us to. I'm all around it, but I'm not going to say it. You were so close to it. But like,
do you think that that will ever kind of happen again? Where there's like a like a rock opera that's kind of like Tommy. Yeah, it's in the beginning to not and not in the classic sense that you're saying it. I mean, there's a great band who we've had played with us the last couple years called Greta Van Fleet. Oh, that love that those guys are great. And they have a they still write longer songs. They, you know, appeal to a very young audience and they still do like crazy long guitar solos. They're really, really great songwriters. They're very dramatic. They're very theatrical, those kids, man.
Yes, they're cool. But super cool. We've had them with us playing a special guest for the last couple of years to our last shows. But I don't think that... Yeah, but let me tell you something. Jason's idea is good because here's the thing. In Hamilton, the musical Hamilton, it's rapping.
Everybody wraps. It's like, a musical that, people would be floored if you guys used your music or create a new music with your sound. It's never been done. I'm not going to do a musical. What about a musical, ours? That's what I'm saying.
Come on. Let's make some, let's make some news right now. I love the reaction to this face. No, I can see his face. That's a, yeah, guys, we've got it. There it is. The tale of the music. You can use it. Laura, let me ask you this before we're looking for you.
An exclusive. Is that what we're doing? No, we're not, we're not getting into musicals. Sean, for once, just one guest, just leave them out of musicals. Yes. Stop getting everyone on the board. He wants to fucking nobody likes musicals. Lars doesn't like cats. I know. He doesn't. I, listen, I saw Hamilton. I saw OG Hamilton. Yeah. OG OG and was as blown away as everybody else and subsequently saw what four times.
And think that Lynn is amazing. I'm going to challenge the credible on this planet. Oh, it's talent. It's talent. I went back later that night and just like Google then YouTube as much as I could. That clip where he's in the White House, like five, six years earlier,
did you guys see that clip? So Hamilton came out in about 16. This is what oh nine, he was in the White House and was telling Obama and the rest of the gathered there that he was working on a musical about Alexander Hamilton. Yeah, and everybody was just laughing. Yeah.
And then he did like, he did the first five minutes of it afterwards that he got like standing a face. Yeah, he's a genius. He is. Fucking never seen that clip, Jason. No, I'm going to check it out. Oh, it's, you got to check it out. It's just a piano in him rapping.
Yeah. Oh, that's great. Or something like that. check it out. It's just a piano and him rapping. Oh, that's great. Or something like that. Really fucking crazy. Yeah, he's a mega talent. He's a mega talent and guess what? I'll tell you what, let's meet, I'll meet you halfway. Okay.
Okay. My sense is it's going well. So when Metallica has some musical news, you guys can break it. Yes, I love it. I love that. I love this for you. If you'll have me back even just five minutes and we can break it. Yes. I love that. I love that. I love that. I love that. If you'll have me back even just five minutes and we can make it an exclusive for us. You're the fourth host. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth. You're the fourth take you to the market for us. He did, you're a man.
Wow. We was going great to you. We can get into, I read about William Freak and also this morning, or yesterday, and I understand the no mentioning of the great films that he made, and et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. And I did read about the, so people know it because of this strike we can't mention them.
Just a tracinac. Yeah, no, I'm right there with Lars Yeah, listen, he was he was another genius too and I and I and I again I don't want to embarrass you, but you're a genius man. You you've made so much great music for so long Yeah, such a fan you're a nice guy. Yeah, that's that's the that's the patient You don't have to be in you all right vibe and you're such a great dude and it was such a pleasure meeting you all those years ago and having you on your Right back at talking you man And just like I've known you
Continued success dude. Well, thank you. Thanks. I have to get back out. Get back here. We'll go hang out with coupe Let's do it. He's gonna cover him. So I'm sitting up in my publicist's office here in in down in Tribeca And I walked in and was handed this piece of paper. I go, wow, this is high tech. Yeah, I care. Yeah. No limits here. We are top of the heap over here.
It's marvelous. Thank you for saying yes to this guy. Thanks for having me. Thanks for being your pick, Will. I enjoyed the time a couple years ago in France. And it's great to see you guys. It's nice to meet you. Nice to meet you too.
And good luck on the rest of the tour. Yeah. When we have musical news, we'll break it with you. I love it. It would be honor. Thank you, Lars. Thanks, buddy. See you soon.
Thank you, man. Bye. Bye, bye, bye. Wow. That was a great gett Willie. Yeah. You know, it's the interesting about him is, you know, I wasn't one to run out and buy Metallica.
Obviously, I like their songs and know a lot of them and was a fan of them growing up too. But it's rare that the drummer is as famous as the band. It's true. Well, who else? Phil Collins. Phil Collins. Yeah, but Lars and James started
the band right so they formed it together. So you had guitarist and drummer like WAM band. Yeah, I guess I guess boy, that might be the first connection there. Yeah. So which one would Andrew Ritchley be? I guess it would be Lars. Huh, okay. Let's get Lars back on the lower way. And by the way, and let's get James on here real quick, you know what I mean? James that makes you George. So I guess. No, you really very very cool.
He's so cool. He's such a cool dude and he does have such a great vibe and he's so, I don't know, he's, I just love the way you can really access all everything when you ask him a question and he can really access it and he's so sort of concise and he's so quick and. Yes, I like that he's open to sharing anything. Yeah, yeah, I love that. I thought it's a key to keeping a little, a little grip together.
It's just don't be a dick. Yeah, okay. Yeah, 100%. You see me looking at you, Sean and Will. No, he's looking at me. He's looking at me. No, you're looking in the mirror, you're looking in the mirror. No, not looking at my square. You're square. Just laptop. You're gonna see I can't believe we miss them at giant or met life, whatever. I think it's a great idea if they open for us.
But we should leave you as close. If you ask for metallic. It's so great that he was offering. I'm pretty sure he was offering to open for us. Yeah, let's wait till they get a little closer to Los Angeles. I know, but they are because they're on tour for their record 72 seasons. And it would be great to go and we should definitely go see them in Los Angeles. That'd be so fun. That'd be fine.
I would love to see. I'm going to go see Tate Tate tomorrow night. Are you? I think that's what is not what kids or kids are calling her. Tate Tate's lefty. Yeah. Are you going to Tate Tate tomorrow? Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Are you taking Franny and MAP? No, no, just solo. Just a one. Just a one. It's going to be in the parking lot with a little sign. Single.
Single. Single. Anyone got a single? No, it will be a full family. Thanks video of your self to alone. Yeah, she's part of the family and we're all going to go and a self driver over. No, I'll be self driving, you know, don't drink anymore. So I know, I know, but I know how you know, we get into the state, where's it? So if I it's at so far, yeah, And apparently you got to pick an album to sort of dress as, and I don't know.
Name one of our albums, one. Name one of our albums. I couldn't. I'm going to go ahead and see what I'm wearing right now. That's what it'll be tomorrow night. Oh, you know what I refer to that is the, the, the, the, fuck it. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. You got a lot of buckets. Wasn't George Costanza's, if you wear sweats, you're were a sweats, you're telling the world you've given up? I mean, I guess so. There it is, Sean is giving up. Oh, look, Sean. Look, I have something to say. If Metallica can't open for us at every single leg of our tour,
if we tour again, they should just do at least at one of them or two of them just do a fly. Bye! Don't do the flying. Don't do the flying. Bye, smart. Bye, smart. Bye, smart.
Smart. Bye. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barberco. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Every big moment starts with a big dream. But what happens when that big dream turns out to be a big flop. From Wondry and Atwell Media, I'm Misha Brown and this is the big flop. Every week, comedians join me to chronicle the biggest flugs, fails, and blunders of all time like Quibi.
It's kind of like when you give yourself your own nickname and you try to like get other people to do it. And the 2019 movie adaptation of... Cats. Like if I'm watching the dancing and I'm noticing the feet aren't touching the ground, there's something wrong with the movie. Find out what happens when massive hype turns into major fiasco. Enjoy the Big Flop on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to the Big Flop early and ad-free on Wondery Plus.
Get started with your free trial at Wondery.com slash plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.